Parag in Parliament you've probably
never heard of it
it means end in the parliamentary
session and shutting this place down
King Charles the first did it in the
17th century to get his way and it
ultimately cost him his head now some in
the Tory Party appear to have lost
theirs
Dominic Rob this week refusing to rule
out suspend in Parliament to force
through brexit it's an idea that
horrifies the man who speaks for this
place and the people in it
Parliament will not be evacuated from
the centre stage of the decision-making
process on this important matter that's
simply not going to happen it's just so
blindingly obvious that it almost
doesn't need to be stated but apparently
it does and therefore I have done speak
of barkos former adversary in the
Commons and now two leadership candidate
and real Edison for once agrees / oak in
Parliament yes there has been some
discussion
Dominic Rob said that he would be
prepared to promote Parliament to push
through no deal what's the reality it
was felt that it would not be something
workable to Pro Road Parliament it's
certainly not something I would seek to
do no no I'm you know I'm passionate
about parliamentary democracy and so yes
it was my job to make sure I understood
the implications of different outcomes
but certainly not because it was nothing
else attempting to do Andrew Knudsen has
her own ideas that's it she wants some
managed exit laws on citizens rights and
cross-border flights to soften the
impact of leaving or knocked over the
31st without a deal she hopes even
states will do the same the key thing
about all of you yes it requires
reciprocity from the EU and you cannot
look at the British people in the eye
and say I'm absolutely sure it will be
fine because but then that's really a
certainty in policy
is never a given this is going to be in
their interest as much if not more than
it's in our interest to do so you've
gotta sit here homie and tell the
British people actually the people
watching this that there isn't going to
be any risk of disruption to their lives
there is no certainty in life Beth
mrs. lead Sims brexit plan is one of
many to be dissected in this race we
don't know which plan will win out but
we do know whoever wins will have to
face a parliament opposed to a No Deal
they can't get around it they will have
to at least try to get through it Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster